bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 16 mai
plusieurs mois de travail concrétiser
les équipes de génération lully était
sur la scène de la merise de trappes
pour présenter leurs créations et nous
reviendrons sur cette oreille que le
directeur du centre de musique baroque
de versailles
une découverte nocturne insolite la nuit
des musées revient à 50 ans l'aîné cette
nouvelle édition est placée sous le
signe de la télévision le thème de
l'exposition temporaire du musée de la
ville à breda et vous pourrez vivre
comme en 1900 une époque faste pour la
famille propriétaire du château
les têtes couronnées les grandes figures
artistiques s'y succèdent costumes
d'époque et reconstitutions vous
attendent
fini les répétitions voici le temps des
représentations et hier soir à la mairie
c'était l'aboutissement d'un projet long
de deux ans nous découverte plus une
création tous les participants de
génération du lit présenter baptiste où
l'opéra des farceurs leurs créations
regarder
[Musique]
approché messieurs dames approché pour
découvrir ce baptiste originale la
création de génération lully et sur
scène la conclusion de neuf mois de
travail initié par le centre de musique
baroque de versailles
on les a vu grimper en quinze jours
d'une façon spectaculaire et c'est un
travail qui leur a été demandé tous les
jours où ils ont chanté dansé vous ont
découvert les costumes le décor l'
orchestre les chanteurs etc où se sont
mêlés avec les autres groupes de trappes
et je pense que là le
la mayonnaise a commencé à prendre deux
arrêtes de madère pour raconter
l'histoire des farceurs ces artistes qui
contournait les interdits royaux sur
scène près 250 chanteurs comédiens et
danseurs des professionnels des
collégiens et des associations
trappistes et je me suis dit de le faire
parce que c'est le truc comme ça on ne
fait pas ça tous les jours où est donc
me suis dit de faire on a
beaucoup appris à danser
ça c'est pas
[Musique]
ses marques
alors que les théâtres ont fait tout le
temps à l'école avec les profs de
français
dès que j'ai commencé à faire les
grandes réflexions à la mauvaise quand
on commence à se rassembler ce qui a
beaucoup de personnes et c'est un grand
truc que vous avez c'est du couchois
dire qu'il ya une danse que tu de
champenoises la première partie qui est
une danse que les bretons
adoptez aménagé pour eux et la deuxième
dans ce qu'on fait c'est une création
totale de nos adhérents plus d'une heure
de spectacle au coeur du xviie siècle
pour ceux qui n'auraient pas pu se
déplacer
séance de rattrapage à l'opéra royal
jeudi 17 mai
[Musique]
nicolas bûcher vous êtes le directeur du
centre de musique baroque de versailles
hier soir il y avait beaucoup
d'impatience mais beaucoup d'impatience
évidemment puisque après un projet qui
date quasiment de deux ans qui a duré
quasiment deux ans le fait d'arriver
enfin au spectacle évidemment c'est une
grande impatience mais c'est aussi
beaucoup d'émotion deux ans il ya eu
neuf mois de création et avant il y
avait la découverte parce que c'est tout
un petit monde sans fin quand je le dis
dans le sujet qui fait devait se
découvrir avant
exactement c'est 1000 personnes touchées
sur l'ensemble du projet avec une année
de découverte et 150 personnes qui sont
acteurs du spectacle sur sept dernières
années cette deuxième année de
préparation du spectacle alors avec un
tel succès on l'a vu moi j'ai rencontré
à plusieurs reprises des équipes on a
senti l'engagement mais même des plus
jeunes les toupies enfin les tout petits
essais des adolescents mais est-ce qu'un
autre projet comme ça va voir le jour
est ce que ça motif de recours de
continuer mais on l'espère évidemment
parce que c'est un tel plaisir de voir
tout ce monde rassemblés sur une scène
pour un si beau spectacle
encadrés par des professionnels j'ai des
plus grands professionnels du milieu de
l'opéra en france aujourd'hui
donc évidemment on espère ce type de
projet à un autre type de projet de
cette envergure on est en train
d'interroger nos financeurs sur le sujet
pour pour obtenir l'assurance de la
poursuite de cette séance de projets
donc affaire à suivre
exactement alors vous nicolas bûcher
vous êtes le directeur mais depuis
seulement deux mois en fonction le 1er
mars sur une année un peu particulière
ce que le cmb a fêté ses 30 ans
exactement l'anniversaire des 30 ans du
cmbv c'était en 2010 est l'année
dernière et voilà le changement de
direction qui n'a rien à voir avec les
trente ans d'ailleurs et je suis arrivé
le 1er mars comme comme vous le dites
avec un immense plaisir à un grand
honneur et
tous deux travaillent à peine plus de
deux mois c'est suffisant pour découvrir
l'établissement où vous faites encore
des découvertes en bas je fais à mon
avis j'ai encore de découverte pour un
petit moment
le c'est plus de deux mois en fait parce
que j'ai été officiellement nommé début
décembre
et donc j'ai organisé mon emploi du
temps pour pouvoir déjà passé quelques
journées en décembre en janvier en
février pour préparer mon arrivée alors
avant d'arriver au cv vous formé au
conservatoire de lille de bruxelles de
lyon vous sauvez le directeur des études
musicales vous diriger ensuite la cité
de la voix avait gelé et vous avez une
carrière d'organiste la musique baroque
les passions la musique baroque c'est
même le début de ma carrière c'est
quasiment avec la musique de couperin
avec la musique de ces compositeurs de
lully que j'ai commencé la musique en
1987 qui est l'année de la création du
centre de musique baroque c'est un
hasard mais mais c'est plaisant c'est un
hasard plaisant et donc oui la musique
baroque et la musique baroque française
je la pratique depuis plus de 30 ans
pourquoi avoir accepté ses fonctions de
directeur du cmbv d'une nouvelle étape
nous envie d'avancer avec eux oui en
fait le cycle avait gelé s'achever j'ai
passé six ans avec les jets mener des
grands travaux pour la création de cette
cité de la voix et j'avais encore
quelques temps a passé là-bas
normalement mail annonce du poste du
centre de musique baroque de versailles
m'a tout de suite tout de suite appelé
vraiment parce que c'était c'est une
maison exceptionnel et c'était vraiment
un endroit où je savais que je serais
heureux parce que justement je pense que
la matière dont il est question cette
musique je l aime beaucoup je la
pratique je la joue donc j'étais heureux
de de travailler à cela et ce que j'aime
énormément dans cette maison justement
c'est la pluralité d'action on a des
projets comme génération du lit mais on
a un centre de recherche
on a des éditions de formation j'aime
j'aime énormément justement travaillé
sur divers actions autour d'un même
sujet et justement qu'est ce que vous
aimeriez apportez-vous au cnvb d'autres
projets alors d'autres projets
j'espérais
vraiment qu'on va pouvoir avoir plus de
formation notamment des formations
instrumentales
on va travailler à cela moi j'essaye et
je considère que c'est mon premier
travail c'est de d'avoir encore plus de
transversalité à l'intérieur de
l'établissement c'est à dire de mêlée de
plus en plus des propos des programmes
qui associe la recherche la formation et
la production l'action culturelle et
j'espère aussi que on va réussir à
enterrer territorialisée notre action en
quelque sorte c'est à dire qu'on sera
plus présent sur le département des
yvelines on est en discussion en ce
moment avec le conseil départemental et
j'espère que on aura de bonnes nouvelles
prochainement mais également au niveau
national et au niveau de l'île de france
en tout cas je souhaite qu'on crée plus
de lien avec les territoires
merci n'est que la bûche est devenu en
plateau et pour découvrir le cnvb encore
quelques rendez-vous même si la saison
touche à sa fin le 17 mai génération
glee et les jeudis musicaux au château
de versailles
aversa il n'y a pas que du baroque parce
que jusqu'au 23 mai on peut aussi
écouter du jazz avec le faire ça et ce
jazz festival pour cette quinzième
édition onze formations répondent
présents pour des concerts et des master
class des précisions d'olivier si lol le
président de l'association
nous avons une programmation chaque
année que l'on cherche à rendre aussi
ouverte si éclectique que possible et
aussi facile d'accès pour chacun même
ceux qui ne sont pas des habitués du
jazz donc cette année nous nous avons
mis un peu l'accent sur le sur le vocal
puisque nous aurons deux groupes avec
chanteurs de groupe avec chanteuse et
une chorale gospel la rédaction souhaité
rendre hommage un dessinateur william
vance et nous a quittés le 14 mai
dernier
l'artiste belge reconnu pour ses traits
fins et précis et est notamment l'un des
pères du héros amnésique 13 tv 78
l'avait rencontré en 2011 à l'occasion
d'une exposition sur versailles
il partageait ses inspirations
influencé par les illustrateurs nick
collins qui
du nom geographic magazine moi aussi ça
donne une bonne et tous ceux de vie
américaine que ses plus hauts rangs de
la guerre je les avais vus à cause de
moi j'étais vraiment plu par sa samedi
19 mai les musées vous invite à veiller
avec eux c'est la nuit des musées bien
sûr le musée de la ville de saint
quentin en yvelines y participent et
nous a rejoint en plateau armelle
ouvriers la vice présidente en charge de
la culture de l'agglomération bonjour
bonsoir
alors cette année le musée fait son show
télé oui tout ça correspond au thème de
l'exposition temporaire que nous avons
et qui se termine 9 h au en fin juillet
20 mi juillet c'est le moment de venir
en auvergne et en profiter ça montre
l'évolution de la télévision et en
particulier comme c'était en pleine
époque de la création de la ville
nouvelle en a toute l'évolution des
écrans pas bon ça c'est ce que fait
soi-même et de 50 ans dans le cadre de
la nuit des musées il y aura une visite
guidée à 20 heures de cette exposition
intemporel et à partir de 20h30 pourra
continuer à le visiter jusqu'à 22 heures
jusqu'à 20 août après sept ans visé mais
en visite libre
alors oui il ya l'exposition celle là
c'est la temporaire et le public est mis
à contribution
est ce qu'il ya une animation avec des
liquides théâtre alors déclic théâtre
fait son show télé donc décliné à tous
et de l'improvisation à partir des
thèmes qui seront fixées par le public
et y aura donc deux séances une à 20h30
une à 21h30 qui se passeront sur le
parvis du musée
en espérant que le temps ça avec
avec nous et c'est intéressant déclic au
théâtre c'est l'improvisation c'est
déclic théâtre c'est l'association qui a
formé jamel debbouze issa doumbia et en
même temps je trouve ça très intéressant
de voir en fait à quelles réflexions
justement ils peuvent nous amener avec
leur humour particulier sur justement
par exemple l'évolution de la télévision
qu'est ce que l'on fait de la demande en
autrui quels regards et les différentes
facettes l'utilisation de la télévision
ouvrir le musée le soir même si c'est
national voire européen c'est aussi
amener un autre public qui serait pas
qui se dirait je vais pas en journée
mais pourquoi oui je pense que c'est une
manière de le faire reconnaître je pense
aussi qu'au niveau de même delà du
territoire moi je pense que le musée est
une bonne image du territoire pour les
l'extérieur du territoire
il s'agit qu'un et j'aimerais qu'on ait
quelque chose au moment de la ryder cup
justement pour faire connaître notre
territoire
mais je pense aussi que les habitants ne
se rendent pas que ne me connaissent pas
et il ne serait pas compte de ce que ça
leur rapporte sur leurs racines en fait
sur ce territoire
et justement ses racines fait
l'exposition fait elle m'a nantes est
elle aussi sera accessible ce soir là on
peut plonger
elle s'est depuis là depuis la
préhistoire en fait
et puis il ya aussi tout le siècle de
vercia de versailles toute la
construction de la ville
de la ville nouvelle les différents
essais d'urbanisme qui ont été faits oui
c'est extrêmement important et surtout
c'est ce sont nos racines et en plus le
musée a changé de place donc la wii mais
se passe encore plus emporté et en fait
c'est à danser il a il a changé de place
et en particulier sur la partie aux
permanents de dire certains mais il ya
énormément de moyens nouveaux de et donc
on peut il ya des écrans on peut
questionner un certain nombre de choses
dont on peut visualiser donc il n'est
pas très grand et mais il ya des tables
d'interactions possibles et à partir de
ce moment là on peut creuser le sujet
que l'on a envie de code approfondie on
est à quelques jours de cette nuit de
nous et les équipes sont prêtes
oui c'est sûr un problème à ce problème
en plus ils sont très fiers de ce qu'ils
ce qui fait reculer le titre de ce
qu'ils ont fait est tout à fait prêt à
le partager
sauf que dans les réserves il ya encore
huit mille objets c'est une très très
belle collection qu'elle possède le
nezet puis le musée bon là ça sera pas
le cas parce que c'est la nuit des
musées
mais le musée aussi c'est tout tous les
parcours tous les parcours sur la ville
sur le territoire et ça aussi il faut y
penser quand on reçoit quand on reçoit
les villes jumelles quand on reçoit des
personnes de l'extérieur quand il ya des
groupes des différentes villes de faire
le parcours et voir ce que je sais que
saint quentin en yvelines
il ya tout musée de la vie merci à lui
brillé alors pour ne rien rater de cette
soirée
la programmation est disponible sur le
site de la vie mais d'autres sites sont
aussi à découvrir à la nuit tombée par
exemple à magny les hameaux de 18h30 à
19h30 53 dessins français sont à
découvrir l'exposition traits divin se
poursuit et la soirée se terminera en
musique avec les variations goldberg de
bach jouée par la claveciniste béatrice
martin vous pouvez aussi vous laisser
tenter par quatre autres lieux évinois à
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse vous pouvez
plonger dans l'humour de raymond
vo ça à versailles eugène viollet le duc
est exposé au musée lambinet le château
n'est pas en reste les lieux les plus
prestigieux se pareront de couleur
inédite grâce au coucher du soleil
et si vous souhaitez aller du côté de
rambouillet c'est leur embolie train qui
a prévu un éclairage spécial et une
balade nocturne
alors ce week end est un week-end chargé
pour la culture parce qu'un inverse
l'invité nous a rejoint en plateau on
part en 1900 avec vous christophe leray
vous êtes scénographe vous allez
participer un rendez vous historique au
château de breteuil
oui c'est ce dimanche 20 mai toute la
journée à partir de 10h30 jusqu'à 18h30
un vaste programme d'activités attendent
les petits comme les grands visiteurs
c'est un voyage à travers l'histoire que
nous leur proposons en 1900 c'est pas
anodin pour le château c'est une période
assez faste c'est une période de grands
changements pour le château de breteuil
c'est un château familial depuis 400 ans
mais là en 1900 nous sommes à l'époque
du grand père de l'actuel marquis de
breteuil henry de breteuil et avec sa
femme marcelle ita garner ils
entreprennent d'immenses travaux au sein
même du château ils vont apporter tout
le confort moderne
j'attends qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
c'est quasiment le château qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui alors il y a eu l'ouverture
au public
il y à 49 ans donc beaucoup de
transformations depuis mai quand même
sur l'organisation du parc du château
la distribution des pièces on est
vraiment sur un château de la belle
époque un château 19 cents et c'est une
époque on peut croiser notamment le roi
d'angleterre edouard 7 et même marcel
proust et oui c'était ces personnages-là
faisait partie du cercle de d'henri de
breteuil
on est avec de grandes têtes couronnées
donc le roi d'angleterre mais aussi de
grandes figures du milieu artistique
marcel proust dans son sa recherche du
temps perdu
henri de breteuil et cités mais avec un
autre nom c'est hannibal de bréauté et
ce il porte les initiales
hb donc hb en fait c'est lui même puis
il y à la comédienne réjane donc une
grande comédienne de théâtre également
alors il va y avoir là ce week-end donc
on va rendre notre sens c'est une
reconstitution avec une trentaine de
figurants vous allez faire revivre
l'époque et 17 se plonger dedans on doit
être costumes et nous aussi
alors il y a effectivement des
reconstitueurs donc là le château de
breteuil modèle et l'entreprise de
l'histoire retrouver et bien organisons
toutes les apparitions des tableaux
vivants donc avec des personnes qui
réalisent souvent leurs costumes eux
mêmes et qui vont être mises en scène à
travers des tableaux vivants d évocation
de la vie d'autrefois essentiellement et
puis cet événement est ouvert au public
alors si il vient justement le public
soit de venir costumé en habit 19/100
c'est tout à fait possible
l'idée c'est qu'il y ait une interaction
entre les époques entre les personnes
aussi entre passionnés curieux
exactement vous avez tout résumé
alors on a beaucoup parlé costumes et
qui dit costumes dit couture et nous
partons à la rencontre d'une personne
que vous connaissez bien christophe
pascal brain elle crée des costumes de
scène elle s'occupe notamment de ceux de
la troupe que vous présidez c'est aussi
président de la troupe du crâne mais
elle fait aussi de la reconstitution et
marion tac et manon varaldo vous
rencontrer
s'installer à sa machine à coudre un
geste que pascal brain pratique chaque
jour c'est doit créer costumes de scène
et costumes d'époque les costumes
d'époque étaient construits à la main
donc les techniques sont différentes
quand on passe à la machine à coudre on
n'a pas forcément la place de passer la
machine à coudre donc il faut qu'on joue
pour russe compte on veut gagner du
temps et ne pas le faire à la main c'est
combien d'heures de travail entre 60 et
70 heures de travail
rien qu'en confection mais quand il en
avait parlé je l'avais déjà dans la tête
je savais qu'elle manteau je voulais lui
faire j'avais une idée de manteaux
renaissance cette yvelinoise lance en
2014 son entreprise au fil de l'histoire
avec son fils celle qui coûte depuis
l'âge de 7 ans est autodidacte ont fait
on des faits on naissait à ce que ça
ressemble d'abord un vêtement qu'on a
pris dans son armoire et qu on copie et
puis on démonte et on essaie d'y arriver
le plus près possible puis ça se fait
tout seul parce qu'elles prennent tous
pour des châteaux les amis de charles
perrault et la troupe saint-quentinoise
la troupe du crâne
c'est une femme justement dans les
coulisses qui hélas toujours aux petits
soins qui va veiller au moindre détail
qui aussi à l'autorité qu'il faut pour
gérer des coulisses parce que ça c'est
vraiment très important de gérer une
équipe de 12 personnes ou voire plus les
commandes que nous faisons un pascal
elles sont importantes
ça peut être tout un vestiaire a créé
sur une thématique précise
un costume représente jusqu'à un mois de
travail
la recette pour faire un bond dans le
passé ces costumes on va pouvoir en voir
dimanche ah oui l'idée justement c'est
que ce soit que l'histoire prenne vie
donc là on n'est pas sur une image figée
au contraire vous allez avoir des
tableaux vivants donc vraiment des
figurants dissimulées un peu partout à
breteuil il y à des personnages de cire
du musée grévin
dans certaines pièces ils vont être
retirés pour être remplacé par de vraies
personnes
donc effectivement tout au long de la
journée en plus il y à des activités des
animations qui vont permettre de
rencontrer la famille de breteuil leurs
amis de grandes figures donc artistique
proust réjane et puis également tout le
personnel on va découvrir aussi l'envers
du décor les coulisses de la vie d'une
famille je vous l'avais dit il ya
différents rendez-vous la programmation
est conséquente je pense que le public
va devoir faire des choix tout à fait il
y a les cuisines les scènes de vie du
personnel les contes de perrault
on est quand même au château de breteuil
course en sac pour les enfants un sac de
jute
oui c'est l'idée de vraiment oublier que
nous sommes en 2018
oui c'est un moment d'évasion et puis
aujourd'hui on est dans une dynamique
d'histoire vivante à breteuil il y à
vraiment la cible familiale et cette
idée de transmission du patrimoine la
volonté d'intéresser toutes les
générations
alors autant les férus d'histoire
pourront être satisfaits avec des
anecdotes une reconstitution souvent
précises qui seront arrêtées
oui ce sont des choses qu'on écrit qu'on
qu'on met en scène qu'on
sur lesquels on se documente aussi
beaucoup pour ne pas faire n'importe
quoi et puis à côté il ya aussi cette
volonté de proposer une journée de
divertissement
d'où les courses en sacs de jute ce qui
était un sport un véritable sport en
1911 va aussi rencontrer augustine et
ses barbes à papa
on passe les auditions au théâtre avec
réjane voilà il ya c'est un équilibre en
fait pour être le plus fédérateur
possible est un temps fort le défilé de
l'élégance le plus beau costume la
meilleure tenue
alors il n'y aura pas de là il n'y a pas
de concours l'idée c'est justement qu'on
puisse participer et lors de ce défilé
de l'élégance autour du miroir d'eau
l'après midi en plus il y aura beau
temps donc nous avons énormément cher je
croise les doigts ne faut pas vendre la
peau de l'ours avant de l'avoir tué
mais justement lors de ce défilé est
bien les reconstitueurs pourront être
rejoints par des visiteurs venus
eux-mêmes costumés et il y aura pauline
bord de l'histoire retrouver qui
commentera les réalisations des uns des
autres qui ajoutera des anecdotes sur
l'histoire du costume féminin masculin
les différentes utilisations de ces
costumes les codifications vraiment les
codes exactement avec des petites
anecdotes ça restera très chaleureux
merci christophe lesort la
reconstitution du château de breteuil en
1900 c'est le dimanche 20 mai et on
passe maintenant à notre page cinéma
[Musique]
et après un voyage dans le passé un
voyage dans les étoiles c'est le coup de
coeur cinéma de bertrand pinet de2 à te
sentir l'école regarder cette semaine
c'est un événement qui se passera dans
deux semaines en comme tous les ans
depuis sept ans on organise un festival
qui s'appelle qui s'appelle donc les
yeux pleins d'étoilés
cette année la thématique est vraiment
une thématique des étoiles puisque c'est
la science fiction
on aura donc le prochain star wars solo
dès la deuxième semaine dès le 30 mai
pour deux semaines quinze séances à prix
défiant toute concurrence mais on aura
aussi quatre événements le premier
événement c'est une soirée autour de la
robotique avec nothing to hide et loane
viol d'un film de werner herzog autour
des nouvelles technologies et de la
robotique avec des dalles et route 66
deux associations qui nous sommes
partenaires sur cette soirée le
lendemain on aura donc ça c'est le
samedi le dimanche 3 on aura là
venue d'un artiste un musicien qui joue
du thérémine un instrument étrange
électronique qui a produit le son de
l'espace de tous les films des années 50
et on projettera le jour où la terre
s'arrêta la première version
un très beau film de patrimoine donc et
puis la semaine suivante le week-end du
8 9 et 10 juin on clôturera notre petite
session de programmation autour de la
science fiction avec le vendredi 8 une
soirée animations on passera
mutafukaz qui est un film franco
japonais qui sort en ce moment et puis
deux monuments de l'animation japonaise
perfect blue qui ressort dans une copie
numérique et akira qui est un des grands
monuments du de l'arrivée de l'animé au
cinéma alors tout ça se déroulera donc
du 2 juin au 10 juin au cinéma les yeux
d'elsa et nous vous espérons nombreux
homos maintenant sur une exposition
originale à guyancourt yan allegret a
collecté des rêves vos rêves sans les
modifier 85 habitants ont accepté de
partager leur rêve ou cauchemar qui sont
devenus un son et lumière à la salle
d'exposition de la ville on les écoute
dans mon travail je me suis toujours
posé la question
comme j'ai eu la chance de beaucoup
voyager je me suis toujours posé la
question qu'est-ce qui peut relier
toutes les personnes quel que soit leur
âge leur nationalité leur culture leur
langue
j'ai trouvé des endroits comme ça vous
des terrains communs il ya un terrain
que je trouve particulièrement
intéressant parce que il a à la fois
très intime et en même temps c'est
quelque chose qui est qui a toujours
marqué toutes les sociétés où toutes les
civilisations s'en sont emparés iront
chercher des signes des prophéties des
dialogues avec chris young la
psychanalyse c'est le rêve bien sûr
l'intégralité de cet entretien est à
retrouver sur notre site internet tv 78
points comme et c'est l'adresse où vous
pourrez aussi retrouver ce 7,8 culture
car c'est la fin de ce numéro et je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve mercredi prochain
[Musique]